The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TOMASO POGGIO: So I'll speak
about i-theory, visual cortex,
deep learning networks.
The background for this is
this conceptual framework
that we take as a
guide to present work
in vision in this center--
The idea that you have a
phase in visual perception,
essentially up to
the first saccade--
say, 100 milliseconds
from onset of an image--
in which most of the
processing is feedforward
in the visual cortex.
And that top-down signals--
I hate the term
feedback in this case,
but back projections going
from higher visual areas,
like inferotemporal cortex, back
to V2 and other cortical areas
are not active in this
first hundred milliseconds.
Now, all of this is a conjecture
based on a number of data.
So it has to be proven.
For us it's just a
motivation, a guide,
to first studying feedforward
processing in, as I said,
the first 100
milliseconds or so.
And to think that other types of
theory, like generative models,
probabilistic inference
that you have heard about,
visual routines you have
heard kind of from Shimon,
are important not so much in
the first 100 milliseconds,
but later on.
Especially when feedback
through back projection,
but also through
movements of the eyes
that acquire new images
depending on the first one you
have seen, come into play.
OK.
This is just to
motivate feedforward.
And of course, the evidence
I refer to is evidence like--
you have heard from Jim DiCarlo,
for the physiology there
is quite a bit of data showing
that neurons in IT become
active and selective for what
is in the image about 80 or 90
milliseconds after
onset of the stimulus.
And this basically implies that
there are no big feedback loops
from one area to another one.
It takes 40 milliseconds to
get to V1, and 10 milliseconds
or so for each of
the next areas.
So the problem is,
computational vision--
the guy on the
left is David Marr.
And here it's really
where most probably
a lot of object
recognition takes
place, is the ventral
stream from V1 to V2,
V4, and the IT complex.
So that's the back of the head.
As I said, it takes
40 milliseconds
for electrical signals to
come from the eye in the front
through the LGN back
to neurons in V1.
Simple complex cells.
And then for signals to go
from the back to the front,
that's the feedforward part.
And on the bottom right, you
have seen this picture already.
This is from Van Essen,
edited recently by Movshon.
It's the size of the areas
and the size of the connection
are roughly proportional to the
number of neurons and fibers.
So you see that V1
is as big as V2.
they both have about
200 million neurons.
And V4 is about 50 million,
and the inferotemporal complex
is probably 100 million or so.
Our brain is about
one million flies.
A fly is around
300,000 neurons or so.
A bee is one million.
And as I think Jim
DiCarlo mentioned,
there are these models
that have been developed
since Hubel and Wiesel--
so that's '59-- that tried to
model feedforward processing
from V1 to IT.
And they start with simple
and complex cells, this S1
and C1, simple cells being
essentially equivalent to Gabor
filters, oriented Gabor
filters in different positions,
different orientations.
And then complex cells that
put together the signals
from simple cells of the
same orientation preference,
but different position, and
so have some more position
tolerance than simple cells.
And then a repetition of this
basic scheme, with S2 cells
that are representing
more complex--
let's call them features--
than lines.
Maybe a combination of lines.
And then C2 cells
again pulling together
cells of the same
preference in order
to get more invariance
to position.
And there is evidence from the
old work of Hubel and Wiesel
about simple and
complex cells in V1.
So S1 and C1, although
the morphological identity
of complex and simple cells
is still an open question--
you know, which specific cells.
We can discuss that later.
But for the rest, this hierarchy
continuing in other areas,
like V2 and V4 and IT,
this is one conjecture
in model like this.
And we, like other
ones before us,
modeled back 15 years
ago this different area.
It's V1, V2, and V4
with this kind of model.
And the reason to
do so was not really
to do object
recognition, but it was
to try to see
whether we could get
the physiological properties
of a different sense
in such a feedforward
model, the ones
that people have had recorded
from and published about.
And we could do that to
reproduce the property.
Of course, some of them
we put in properties
of simple and complex cells.
But other ones, like how
much invariance to position
there was in the top
level, we got it out
from the model
consistent with the data.
One surprising thing that
we had with this model
was that, although it was not
designed in order to perform
well at object recognition, it
did actually work pretty well.
So the kind of things you
have to think about this
is rapid categorization.
You have seen that already.
And the task is, for each image,
is there an animal or not?
And you can kind of get the
feeling that you can do that.
In the real experiment,
you have an image and then
a mask, another image.
And then you can say
yes, there is an image,
or no, there is not.
This is called rapid
categorization.
It was introduced
by Molly Potter,
and more recently Simon
Thorpe in France used it.
And it's a way to
force the observer
to work in a feedforward mode,
because you don't have the time
to move your eyes, to fixate.
There is some
evidence that the mask
may stop the back
projections from working.
So this is a
situation in which you
could compare human performance
to these feedforward models,
which are not a complete
description of vision anyway,
because they don't take into
account different eye fixation
and feedbacks and
higher processes, like--
like I said, probabilistic
inference and routines.
Whatever it happens, very likely
in normal vision, in which you
have time to look around.
So in this case, this
d prime is a measure
of performance, how well
you're doing this task.
And you can see, first of
all, the absolute performance,
80% correct on a
certain database.
This task, animal no animal,
is similar between the model
in humans.
And images that are
difficult for people,
like images in which
there is a lot of clutter,
the animals are small, are
also difficult for the model.
And the easy ones
are easy for both.
So there is a correlation
between models and humans.
This does not say that the
model is correct, of course,
but it gives a hint that
model of this type capture
something of what's going
on in the visual pathway.
And Jim DiCarlo spoke about
a more sophisticated version
of these feedforward
models, including
training with back propagation,
that gives pretty good results
also in terms of
agreement between neurons
and units in the model.
So the question is
why these models work.
They're very
simple, feedforward.
It has been surprisingly
difficult to understand why
they work as well as they do.
When I started to work on this
kind of things 15 years ago,
I thought this kind of
architecture would not work.
But then they worked much
better than I thought.
And if you believe deep learning
these days, which I do--
for instance, in
performance on ImageNet--
my guess is they work
better than humans,
actually, because the
right comparison for humans
on ImageNet would be the
rapid categorization one.
So they present images briefly.
Because that's what the
models have-- just one image.
No chance of getting
a second view.
Anyway, that's a more
complex discussion
that has to do also
with how to model
the fact that in our
eyes, in our cortex,
every-- solution
depends on eccentricity.
It's a pretty rapidly
decaying resolution
as you go away from
the fovea, and has
some significant implications
for all these topics.
I'll get to that.
What I want to do
today is, one way
to look at this to
try to understand
how these kind of
feedforward models work--
i-theory is based on
trying to understand
how models that are
simple and complex cells
and can be integrated in a
hierarchical architecture
can provide a signature
set of features that
are invariant to transformations
observed during development,
and at the same time
keep selectivity.
You don't lose any selectivity
to different objects.
And then I want to
see what they say
about deep convolutional
learning networks,
and look at some of the--
beginning with theory
about deep learning.
And then I want to look at
a couple of predictions,
particularly related to
eccentricity-dependent
resolution coming
from i-theory, that
are interesting for the sake
of physics and modeling.
And then it's
basically garbage time,
if you're interested
in mathematical details
and proofs of theorems
and historical background.
OK.
Let's start with i-theory.
These are the kind of things
that we want, ideally,
to explain.
This is the visual
cortex on the left.
Models like HMAX, or
feedforward models.
And on the right are
the deep learning
convolutional networks,
a couple of them,
which basically have
convolutional stage
stages very similar to S1, and
pooling stages similar to C1.
But quite a lot of those layers.
How many of you know
about deep learning?
Everybody, right?
OK.
These are the kind of questions
that i-theory tries to answer--
why these hierarchies
work well, what
is really visual cortex,
what is the goal of V1 to IT.
We know a lot about
simple and complex cells,
but again, what is
the computational goal
of these simple
and complex cells?
Why do we have Gabor
tuning in the early areas?
And why do we have
quite generic tuning,
like in the first visual area,
but quite specific tuning
to different types of
objects like faces and bodies
higher up?
The main hypothesis with
starting i-theory is that one
of the main goals of
the visual cortex--
it's a hypothesis-- is to
compute a set of features,
a representation of images, that
is invariant to transformations
that the organism
has experienced--
visual transformations--
and remains selective.
Now, why is
invariance important?
A lot of the problem
of recognizing objects
is the fact that I can
see once Rosalie's face,
and then the next time
it's the same face,
but the image is
completely different,
for it's much bigger
now because I'm closer,
or the illumination
is different.
So the pixels are different.
And from one single object,
you can produce in this way--
through translation, scaling,
different illumination,
viewpoint-- you can produce
thousands of different images.
So the intuition
is that if I could
get a computer description--
say, long vectors of
features of her face--
that does not change under
these transformations,
recognition would
be much easier.
Easier means,
especially, that I could
learn to recognize an object
with much fewer labeled
examples.
Here on the right you have
a very simple demonstration
of what I mean,
empirical demonstration.
So we have at the
bottom different cars
and different planes.
And there is a linear classifier
which is trained directly
on the pixel.
Very stupid classifier.
And you train it with
one car and one plane--
this is on the left--
or two cars, two planes.
And then you test
on other images.
And as you can see,
when it's trained
with the bottom examples, which
are at all kinds of viewpoints
and sizes, the performance of
the classifier in answering
is this a car or is
this a plane, it's 50%.
It's chance.
Does not learn at all.
On the other hand, suppose
I have an oracle which is--
I will conjecture
is visual cortex,
essentially, that
gives you the feature
vectors for each image,
which is invariant
to these transformations.
So it's like having images
of cars in this line B.
They're all in the same
position, same illumination,
and so on, and the
same for the planes.
And I repeat this experiment.
I use one pair--
one car, one plane--
to train, or two
cars, two planes,
and I see immediately that
when tested on new images,
this classifier is close to 90%.
So much better.
So correcting-- having invariant
representation can help a lot.
That's the empirical,
simple demonstration.
And you can prove theorems
saying the same thing,
that if you have an
invariant representation,
you can have a much lower
simple complexity, which
means you need much
fewer labeled examples
to train a classifier to achieve
a certain level of accuracy.
So how can you compute an
invariant representation?
There are many ways to do it.
But I'll describe
to you one which
I think is attractive, because
it's neurophysiologically very
plausible.
The basic assumption
I'm making here
is that neurons are
very slow devices.
They don't do well
a lot of things.
One of the things
they do probably best
is high-dimensional
dot products.
And the reason is that
you have a dendritic tree,
and in cortical neurons you
have between 1,000 and 10,000
synapses.
So you have between
1,000 and 10,000 inputs.
And each input gets
essentially multiplied
by the weight of
the synapse, which
can be changed during learning.
It's plastic.
And then the post-synaptic
depolarization
or hyperpolarization, so
the electrical changes
to the synapses, get all
summated in the soma.
So you have some i.
Xi are your inputs,
Wi are your synapses.
That's a dot product.
And this happens automatically,
within a millisecond.
So it's one of the few
things that neurons do well.
It's, I think, one of the
distinctive features of neurons
of the brain relative to
our electronic components,
that in each neuron,
each unit in the brain,
there are about 10,000
wires getting in or out.
When I say in, transistor
or logical units
in our computers,
the number of wires
is more like three or four.
So this is the assumption,
that this kind of dot products
are easy to do.
And so this suggests
this kind of algorithm
for computing invariance.
Suppose you are a
baby in the cradle.
You're playing with a toy--
it's a bike-- and you are
rotating it, for instance.
For simplicity.
We'll do more complex things.
The unsupervised learning that
you need to do at this point
is just to store the movie
of what happens to your toy.
For instance, suppose you
get a perfect rotation.
This is a movie up there.
There are eight frames.
Yeah.
You store those, and
you keep them forever.
All right.
So when you see a new
image, it could be
Rosalie's face, or this fish.
And I want to compute
a feature vectors which
is invariant to rotation,
even if I've never
seen the fish rotated.
What I do is, I
compute a dot product
of the image of the fish
with each one of the frames.
So I get eight numbers.
And the claim is that
these eight numbers--
not their order,
but the numbers--
are invariant to
rotation of the fish.
So if I see the fish now in
a different rotation angle--
suppose it's vertical, I'd still
get the same eight numbers.
In a different order, probably.
You could have-- these
are eight numbers.
What I said, they are invariant
to rotation of the fish.
There are various
quantities that you
can use to represent
compactly the fact
that they are the same
independent of rotation.
For instance, the
probability distribution--
the histogram-- of these values
does not depend on the order.
And so if you make
a histogram, these
should be independent
of rotation,
invariant to rotation, Or
moments of the histogram,
like the average, the variance,
the moment of order infinity.
And for instance, the equation
for computing a histogram
is written there.
You have the dot product
of the image, the fish,
with one template to
the bike, the bike Tk.
You have several
templates, not just one.
And Gi is the element
of the rotation group.
So you get various
rotations of--
simply because you
have observed that.
You don't need to know
its rotation group.
You don't need to compute that.
These are just images
that you have stored.
And there can be different
thresholds of simple cells.
And sigma could be just
a threshold function,
for instance.
As it turns out--
I'll describe later.
And sum is the pool.
I'll describe later these.
But sigma, the nonlinearities
can be, in fact,
almost anything.
This is very robust to different
choices of the nonlinearity
and the pooling.
Here are some examples in
which now the transformation
is translation that you
have observed for the bike.
And if I compute a histogram--
from more than eight
frames, in this case--
I get the red
histogram for the fish,
and you can see the red
histogram does not change,
even if the image of
the fish is translated.
Same for the blue Instagram,
which is the set to features
corresponding to the cat.
Also it's invariant
to translation.
But it's different
from the red one.
So these quantities,
the histograms,
can be invariant of
course, but also selective,
which is what you want.
In order to have a selectivity
as high as you want,
you need more than one template.
And some results about
how many you need.
I can go into more
details of this.
But essentially, you need
a number of templates--
of templates like the bike,
in your original example--
that is logarithmic in
the number of images
you want to separate.
For instance, suppose you
want to be able to distinguish
1,000 faces, or 1,000 objects.
Then the number of
templates you need
is in the order of log 1,000.
So does not increase so much.
Yeah.
So there are two things,
one, which you implied.
The reason I spoke about
rotation of the image plane,
because rotation
is a compact group.
So you never get out.
You come back in.
The translation, you can--
in principle, mathematically,
between plus infinity or minus
infinity.
Of course it does
not make sense,
but mathematically
this means that it's
a little bit more
difficult to prove
the same results in the case
of translation and scale.
But we can do it.
That's the first point.
The second one,
the combinatorics
of different transformations.
Turns out that--
one approach to this
is to have what the visual
system seems to have,
in which you have relatively
small ranges of invariance
at different stages.
So that at first
stage, say in V1,
you have pooling by
the complex cells
over a small range of
translations, and probably
scale.
And then at the second stage
you have a larger range.
I'll come to that later.
But it's a very
interesting point.
I'll not go into this.
These are-- technical extension
of these partial observer
groups, these
non-compact groups.
The non-group transformation
of this approximate
invariance to rotations in
3D, or changes of expression,
and so on.
And then what happens
when you have--
a hierarchy of just modules.
I'll say briefly
something about each one.
One is that if you look
at the templates that
give you simultaneous--
so what we want to do, we want
to get scale and positioning
invariance.
And suppose you
want templates that
maximize the simultaneous
range of invariance
to scale and position.
It turns out that Gabor
templates, Gabor filters,
are the ones to do that.
So that may be one
computational reason
for why Gabor filters
are a good thing
to do in processing images.
So for getting approximately
good invariance
to non-group
transformations, you
need to have some conditions.
The main one is
that the template
must transform in a similar
way to the object you
are to compute, like faces.
And for these properties
to be true for a hierarchy
of modules.
Think of this inverted
triangle like a set
of simple cells at the
base, and one complex cell,
the red circle at the top.
And so the architecture
that we're looking at
is simple complex.
This would be like V1.
And next to it, another
simple complex module.
This is all V2.
And then you have V1 in
the second layer, that
is getting the input from V1.
And you repeat the same thing,
but on the output of V1.
This is exactly like a
deep learning network.
It's like visual cortex, where
you have different stages
and the effective receptive
fields increases as you go up,
as you see here.
So this would be the
increase in spatial pooling--
so invariance-- and also,
as I mentioned-- not
drawn here, but the scale.
Pooling over size, scale.
And you can show that, if
the following is true, that--
let me see.
Is this animated?
No.
What you need to have-- and a
number of different networks,
certainly the ones
I described, have
this property of covariance.
So suppose you have an object
that translates in the image.
OK.
What I need is that
the neural activity--
the red circles at
the first level--
also translate.
This is covariance.
So what happens
is the following.
Suppose the object is smaller
than those receptive fields,
and this drawing is as big.
But suppose it's smaller.
Then if you translate one of
those receptive fields, going
from one point to another,
because each one has invariance
to translations within
the receptive field--
it's pooling over them--
translation in the
receptive field
will give the same output.
You will have
invariance right there.
But suppose you have
one image, and then
the next one the object moves
to a different receptive field,
or gets out of the
receptive field.
Then you don't have
invariance at the first layer.
But if you have covariance--
or the neural activity moves--
at that layer above,
you may have invariance
under that receptive field.
In other words, in
this construction,
if you have this
covariance property, then
at some point in the network,
one of these receptive fields
will be invariant.
Is that--
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain that again?
TOMASO POGGIO: Yeah.
The argument is-- suppose
I have an object like this.
I have an image.
And then-- I have another image
in which the object is here.
Obviously the response
at this level--
the response of this cell
will change, because before it
saw this object.
Now, there is these
other cells who see that.
So the response has changed.
You don't have invariance.
However, if you look
at what happens, say,
at the top red circle there,
the top red circle will
you see some activity
in the first image
here, because it was
activated for this.
And-- in the second case, we
see some activity over there,
which should be equivalent.
And under these
receptive fields,
translations will give
rise to the same signature.
Under this big
receptive field, you
have invariance for
translation within it.
So the argument is that--
either you have
invariance at one layer,
because the object
just moved within it,
and then you are done.
It's invariant, and
everything else is invariant.
Or you don't have
invariance in this layer,
but you will have it
at some layer above.
So in a sense--
if you go back to this--
I'll make this point later.
But if you go back to this--
to this algorithm,
the basic idea
is that you want to have
invariance to rotation.
And so you average
over the rotations.
But suppose you want
to have invariance--
you want to have an
estimate of rotation,
but you're not
interested in identity.
Then what you do, you
don't pool over rotation.
You pull over different
objects at one rotation.
So you can do both.
All right?
AUDIENCE: My question was more
physiological than theoretical.
TOMASO POGGIO: Yeah.
Physiological-- we had done
experiments long ago in IT
with Jim DiCarlo,
Gabriel Kreiman.
And from the same
population of neurons,
we could read out
identity, object identity,
invariant to scale and position.
And we could also read out
position invariant to identity.
And--
AUDIENCE: The same from the--
TOMASO POGGIO: Same population.
I'm not saying the same neuron,
but the same population of 200
neurons.
And so you can
imagine that you could
have different situations.
One could be some of the neurons
are only conveying position,
and some others are
completely invariant.
And when you read out with
a classifier, it will work.
Or you have neurons
that are already
combining this information,
because the channels--
either way.
OK, let me do this, and
then we can take a break.
I want to make the connection
with simple and complex cells.
We already mentioned this,
but this set of operations,
you can think of this
sigma dot product, n delta,
this is a simple cell.
So this is a dot product of
the image with a receptive
field of the simple cell.
That's what this parenthesis is.
You have a bias, or a
threshold, and the nonlinearity.
Could be the spiking
nonlinearity.
Could be, as I
said, a rectifier.
Neurons don't generate
negative spikes.
And so all of this is very
plausible biologically.
And the simple cell
will simply pool,
take the over the
different simple cells.
So that's what I mentioned
before, that nonlinearity
can be almost anything.
And I want to mention
something that could
be interesting for physiology.
From the point of view
of this algorithm,
this may be a solution to this
problem that has been around
for 30 years or so, which is
that Hubel and Wiesel and other
physiologists after
them identified
simple and complex
cells in terms
of their physiological
properties.
They couldn't see from
where they are recording.
But there were cells that
behaved in different ways.
The simple cells had the
small receptive field.
The complex cell had
larger receptive field.
The complex cells
were more invariant.
And then physiologists
today are using
criteria in which
the complex cell is
more non-linear than
the simple cell.
Now, from the point
of view of the theory,
the real difference is
one is doing the pooling--
the complex cells.
The simple cell is not.
And the puzzle is that despite
these physiological difference,
they were never able to say
this type of pyramidal cell
is simple, and this type of
pyramid cell are complex.
And part of the reason could be
that maybe simple and complex
cells are the same cell.
So that the operation can
be done on the same cell.
If you look at the
theory, what may happen
is that you have one dendrite
play the roll of a simple cell.
You have inputs,
synaptic weights.
So this could give
rise, for instance,
to the Gabor-like
receptive field.
And then-- these other dendrites
to another simple cell.
It's a Gabor-like in a slightly
different position in the image
plane, in the retina.
You need the nonlinearities.
And they may be, instead
of the output of the cell,
they may be so-called
voltage and time dependent
conductancies in the dendrites.
In the meantime, we know
that pyramidal cells
in the visual cortex
have these nonlinearities
like almost having spike
generation in the dendrites.
And then the soma will
summate everything.
This is what the
complex cell is doing.
And if one of the cells
is computing something
like an average, which is one of
the moments of a distribution,
then the nonlinearity
will not even be needed.
And then physiologists, using
the criteria they use this day,
would classify that
cell as simple,
even if from that point
of view of the theory
it's still complex.
Anyway, that's the
proposed machinery
that comes from the theory.
That's everything that we need.
And it will say simple and
complex cell could be one cell.